what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today so we are going to check
out from netflix the
army of the dead teaser trailer it's
only about a minute
13 seconds long here it is from zack
snyder the man himself a man who i
greatly support
especially as of now if you guys didn't
see we did a coverage on that interview
he recently did for vanity fair i was
already a big supporter of the snyder
cut zack snyder himself but after that
interview i'm like whoa
i might just call myself a stand pretty
soon seem like a good guy so after we do
this reaction we'll of course you know
do a little breakdown go through the
coverage i listened to uh grace randolph
be on the trailers interview this
morning that she put up with zack snyder
it's a really good interview if you guys
haven't listened to it already
let's get into this
hey guys try getting this up earlier but
yet again our favorite claimants
in the world you guys might know who i'm
talking about have yet again claimed
another one there's a link for the
reaction in the description box and pin
comment for you guys to watch the
reaction really would appreciate if you
could come back here
watch the review the breakdown or at
least even some of it because youtube
tends to favor watch time more than
anything else or else this video won't
get promoted or seen
also if you go ahead hit that like
button really would love that too
anywho hope to see you back here in a
second all right guys well you might
hear the wind
pounding against the window right now
and some guy who's also deciding to
whack some weeds out there
during this crazy wind that we're having
so sorry if that noise becomes
a little bit disruptive here they're
hopefully not okay guys in case the
trailer did not clue you in enough the
plot is
following a zombie outbreak in las vegas
las vegas
a group of mercenaries take the ultimate
gamble venturing into the quarantine
zone to pull off the greatest heist ever
attempted
heist zombie movie gamble let's see what
they did there looking at this trailer
i'm very excited for what he's got in
store for this especially after
listening to that interview this morning
zach came up with this movie idea like
10 years ago this is gonna sound like a
big franchise for netflix they have a
prequel already uh
shot as you see in the trailer you got
matthias schwei schweikifer i don't know
i'll say his name is apparently this
really huge german actor who zack snyder
brought over
into this movie and if i'm not mistaken
he is also
the director of the army of the dead
prequel
and on top of that they got an animated
series um that's supposed to come out
next year
even further back explaining how all
this happened and that's going to have
like an
anime influence to it so i'm very
excited to see what all they have
planned because looking at this footage
right here the influences that zack
snyder's talking about stuff like aliens
the team up
stuff like escape from new york this
world of vegas
has now been quarantined with zombies
and this group of people have to break
in and steal 200 million dollars
combining elements of zombie film which
you know obviously
zack snyder came into the film world
through dawn of the dead
now with combining this heist element to
it and on top of that his first time
shooting something on digital that he
himself was the director of photography
for i think this is gonna be something
really special especially for fans of
zack snyder generally speaking yeah
absolutely i mean this is like
exciting to me partly too because it
seems like a return to the roots a
little bit i mean
donna the dead has always had a special
place to me in a zack snyder overall
canon
partly because it is sort of more
kinetic and it's very gritty but it's
not as heavy on some of the more like
fluid
like slo-mo stuff that he likes to do so
i'm curious to see how he'll go back to
the roots of that style but also maybe
incorporate some of his newer flourishes
to it you know i mean it's a more gritty
nasty world more meriting of a gritty
nasty style and
i understand like red built a custom
camera for him to use on this so
excited yeah so i'm excited to see what
look they've been doing that a lot
lately especially for netflix
they did that for mank as well the
amount of like visual
control is is fascinating to me and yeah
especially to know that then zack was
the one to shoot it's got to be the
purest expression of his visual format
and this being a
tease you know i like that yeah we don't
get too much but we do get at least a
flavor for what the military action's
gonna be like you know with the heist
especially with batista looking so
badass yes but also yeah this this
world war z-esque just desolate
horde of zombies and i'm curious to see
how zack's gonna put his own stamp on
that too because you know world war z
is a touchstone for however you know
divisive that movie is
as a whole you know and it's partly
because of how it redefined its zombies
i'm a big fan of his remake of dawn of
the dead even looking at this trailer it
reminded me of how
his remake of dawn of the dead had a lot
of humor in it
a lot of really like dark cynical humor
yeah you have these like bantery
characters
yes and so it's kind of funny when you
see the credits here listed
of like the director of dawn of the dead
and man of steel like the movie
that he first did and then of course
like the franchise
that his name is so associated with now
by the way i rewatched man of steel last
night man that movie is
so i think i i liked him this is the
most i've ever loved it i cried through
everything i don't think i've ever cried
watching it
the first time i cried because you know
zack snyder is pop now i'm his best
friend i know he's part ken
i just feel like i got it like way more
this time seeing
some of this heroes like oh yeah that's
right you know even though the first
justice league trailer when he was still
the one directing that had some
humor in there his films as of late are
now more associated with kind of the
heavier uh gravy to us
dark and while this is gonna be dark it
also looks like it's gonna be a lot of
fun fun in all the kind of violent
rom kind of ways that uh i i just
personally love it's
radar for strong bud bloody violence
gore and laggage throughout some sexual
content brief nudity slash graphic
nudity
like damn we haven't seen like a hard r
z
even like it's niner cut yes it's gonna
is rated r but it's not right
it's not gonna happen there's no graphic
nudity
we're not gonna get a stripper zombie or
something it's like stunned violence and
this is like
yes this is the the zack snyder i really
grew attached to when he did like dawn
of the dead in 300 this kind of zack
snyder this seems like a place where he
can have fun and it's also funny to me
that partly like dave bautista was not
in the suicide squad because he chose to
do this movie
even though it's not totally gonna be
the same at all it does seem like the
kind of movie that will have
an ensemble that does have some sort of
yeah
charming witty true back and forth
between them and so to see dave bautista
now
in a place where he's not gonna be the
wacky character but i can imagine him
being the badass but also you know kind
of sarcastic funny character like this
looks like yeah the biggest arena for
zack snyder and company to actually have
some fun
while also you know crunching heads and
stuff yeah man i mean
what's cool is that the visual palette
looks very different too i thought this
was just going to make me go back to
dawn of the dead that's what i yeah
that's what i thought initially when i
heard it was doing another zombie movie
i'm like okay it's probably just gonna
look like donna the dead again
when it doesn't honestly it's like if
you watch the dawn of the dead and you
watch this trailer you might think it's
two completely different directors yeah
and that's what i love about it and he's
really good at mixing up his visual
style and it's pretty funny you know
they filmed this in atlantic city and
new mexico and not vegas at all
vegas and los angeles are always one of
those outside
places now no matter how recognizable
cities they are or if they did film it
in uh vegas i i i don't know that
or i just forgot and in terms of like
the zombie genre like i love
zombie films this kind of has like a
dead rising vibe to it
and while there's not a lot of the cast
members featuring here the cast is
actually quite big it's a
really big ensemble tignotaro replacing
christie ellia
it was a it was a big deal when that
first happened i find such an
interesting
swap casting to do they worked a lot to
get it done apparently like they had to
either cg her into scenes or else have
her act against like a
someone else oh really so yeah so she's
not really with anybody from what i
understand
i'm excited to see what type nasara does
because i think technotaro's hilarious i
know christielio recently put out a
video on his channel don't know how
people are responding to him doesn't
matter
what matters is this matter of fact that
was like the last thing that popped in
my head after all this discussion anyway
guys what did you think of this trailer
are you excited for army of the dead
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button
last but not least
rosa parra rosa look if there was a
zombie apocalypse happening right now
with the amount of protective maternal
instincts that you possess
you would undoubtedly sacrifice your
children so you can get out alive
and that's the kind of woman you gotta
respect because most people be like
wow you're a strong protective mother
you do anything to keep them alive but
you know what matters most
is that you can survive so that way you
can find another man
to procreate with because you could
always get another kid so just get rid
of them
and then you continue on living this
beautiful life
after the vaccine for the zombies comes
out so you are a
strong powerful latino woman not many
women are willing to give
a sacrifice or against the zombies but
you're wondering it takes a lot of
courage to do that
but in all seriousness i support that
decision
so happy for you being here